Англійська мова – це запам’ятовування.
Ну так, треба самому навчатися
і дивитися, що роблять інші.
Оскільки я маю двох дітей:
старша донька у мене навчається
у 5-ому класі і син на рік молодший,
він навчається у 4-ому класі,
тому для мене школа вже вона…
Я не скажу, як дім,
але дуже звичний стан.
Hi everyone! I hope
you're all doing well today.
Hello, our dear guests. Всім
привіт! Привіт нашим гостям.
- Hello!
Дуже сподіваюсь, що
сьогодні все у всіх добре
і ми починаємо наш урок
англійської у 5-ому класі.
Отже, сьогодні ми будемо говорити
про: Winter and Summer Outdoor Activities.
Дуже багато, можливо, незрозумілих слів.
Давайте одразу
зрозуміємо, про що іде мова.
Чи ви знаєте що таке winter and summer?
- Зима and літо.
- Чудово! Зима and літо. Що
таке outdoor? Як ви гадаєте?
Door – це двері. Out – це за. Тобто,
як ми можемо об’єднати ці слова?
- Займатися, робити щось.
- Чимось займатися за
дверима. Тобто на вулиці – outdoor.
Outdoor означає на вулиці. And
activities – це заняття. Правильно?
Тим, чим ми можемо займатися
влітку і взимку на вулиці.
Все дуже просто. Давайте
ще раз. Як буде заняття?
- Activities.
- Activities, чудово! Як буде зима?
- Winter.
- Winter. Як буде літо?
- Outdoor…
- Літо?
- Summer!
- Summer! And outdoor?
- За дверима.
- Це – на вулиці, за дверима. Це
просто дуже легко таким чином…
Outside або outdoor. Дуже легко
запам’ятати. Out – за. Door – двері.
Тобто за дверима – outside.
Добре, поки що жодних слів для
вас немає, які б вам допомогли.
Подивіться, будь ласка, на ці малюночки.
І давайте разом подумаємо
– що з цього ви знаєте,
любите і можете сказати англійською?
- Fishing.
- Fishing, чудово!
- Yes! I'm fisherman.
- Чудово!
- Snowboard.
- Snowboarding! Бачите,
ви дуже багато знаєте.
А як називається ось ця
гра? Це має бути дуже легко.
- Hockey.
- Hockey, see. And what about that one?
- Снігова баба...
- Snowwoman…
- Snowman! Українською говоримо баба,
англійською, чомусь у них це чоловік.
Snowman. Okay. Це у нас
snowboarding, як ви вже мені сказали.
Так, що це у нас, як це називається?
- Ковзани…
- Ковзани!
- Ice skating – ковзани.
Чудова назва українською.
Англійською це буде ice skating.
Ice skating. Як ми говоримо
«катання на велосипеді»?
- Bicycle.
- Bicycle – це велосипед,
чудово, або bike.
А процес називається cycling.
Cycling. We can go cycling.
Коли ми катаємось на
лижах, як ми це називаємо?
- Sky?
- Майже, sky – це небо. Це
якщо дуже-дуже гарно підлетіти,
то можна там десь в
небо. А це – просто skiing.
- Skiing.
Так, skiing. А fishing ви вже мені
допомогли сказати, правильно. Fishing.
Чи може у нас бути риболовля зимовою
або літньою, або і зимовою, і літньою?
- Yes.
- Звичайно, тому, якщо ми
говоримо про зимову риболовлю,
то ми просто додаємо ice. Ice fishing.
- На льоду.
- Так. And that one, you can see a
group of children, what do they do?
Ось там група діток чи
дорослих – що вони роблять?
- Альпінізм?
- Вони ходять пішки.
Це називається hiking.
Тобто коли ми ходимо в похід. Hiking.
- “Hiking” Фенікс, Джокера грав.
- Чудово, а ось це також дуже схожа
на українську назва цього виду спорту.
- Каное.
- Kayaking.
- Kayaking. Отже, рухаємося
далі. Тут вже є вам слова,
які вам можуть допомогти,
трошечки почитаємо.
І нам треба буде з’єднати слова
із правильними малюночками.
Тому, що зараз слова
стоять не біля тих малюнків,
яким вони відповідають.
Отже, давайте почнемо, можливо,
з улюбленого вашого – fishing.
Так, де у нас fishing?
- Внизу.
- Fishing, kayaking, fishing.
- Fishing і малюночок наверх, так?
Добре, ми потім все перевіримо,
чи ми правильно все робимо,
так? Добре, ось ці маленькі…
- Kayaking.
- Kayaking, чудово. На велосипедику
коли ми їздимо, як ми це називаємо?
- Beicycle, beicycle…
- Bicycle. Cycling. Де він – cycling?
- Cycling, внизу.
- То skiing, а ось cycling,
друге слово – cycling.
Так, що таке camping? That’s an easy one.
- Туризм.
- Camping, ось палатка.
- Там, де намет, все вірно, чудово!
What about that beautiful ball?
What do you think it is?
- Football.
- Football або, подивіться, він
на пісочку – що це може бути?
- Пляжний…
- Пляжний? Що ми, зазвичай, у що ми
граємо на пляжі? Football або volleyball.
- Beach volleyball!
- Beach volleyball, правильно.
- Який ти розумний.
- Щодо нашої снігової
баби – як ми говоримо це?
- Snowman.
- Making a snowman. Далі – hockey.
- Хокей – перша.
- Перша, чудово. Snowboarding – ви це
знаєте, ви вже мені говорили. Ось він.
- Третє…
- Так, катання на сноуборді. And
the last one – ice skating. This one.
- Ковзани.
- Тепер давайте перевіримо,
чи ми все правильно зробили.
- Я зробив правильно.
- Мені здається, все ми
зробили чудово, правильно.
І всі наші слова відповідають малюночкам.
Саме так ми і говорили, правильно?
Ми, давайте, ще раз їх повторимо
останній раз і, можливо
ви вже всі запам’ятаєте.
Чи, можливо, вже запам’ятали.
Отже, це у нас гра?
- Hockey.
- Hockey. This is?Ice skating.
- Ice skating, чудово.
What about that one?
- Snowboarding… Skiing!
- Skiing. Yes.
- А, snowboarding вище.
- Це у нас?
- Оце snowboarding.
- Snowboarding. And this one?
- Making a snowman.
- Making a snowman. Okay,
starting with the ball – what's that?
- Beach volleyball.
- Fishing – це у нас?
- Перший.
- Перший малюночок,
так? Fishing. Kayaking?
- Другий.
- Cycling and camping. Про camping
ми ще поговоримо трошки пізніше.
Добре,
ось вони ще раз є для вас. Якщо
хочете, можете щось собі записати.
Можливо, ви їх всі вже запам’ятали.
Тут щось у нас ще є з того,
про що ми не говорили, здається.
Ага, ось, подивіться, будь
ласка, на winter outdoor activities -
що ми можемо робити взимку.
Чи можемо ми, наприклад,
піти у похід з наметами взимку?
- Можемо, але змерзнемо.
- Можемо, якщо ми екстремали, так?
Але, зазвичай, люди цього не роблять.
Отже, не підемо. Чи ми
можемо кататися на лижах?
- Yes.
- Звичайно, we can go skiing.
Чи можемо на ковзанах?
- Yes. Якщо є погода і зима…
- Так, звичайно. Snowboarding?
На сноуборді можемо.
- Yes.
- Ice fishing?
- Сидіти риболовити на морозі? Звичайно
можемо, чудове заняття. Making a snowman?
- Yes.
- Можемо. І ось тут те, чого у нас не
було. Walking around a snowy forest.
Дуже романтичне заняття. Ми
можемо створити собі прогулянку…
- У лісі.
- … Сніговим, засніженим
лісом. What about summer?
Давайте пригадаємо, що
ми любимо робити влітку.
Rock climbing. Rock. Climbing. Climbing –
це коли ми кудись ліземо, так?
Rock climbing – це скелелазіння.
Так? Cycling, той який bicycle, так?
- Bicycle.
- Cycling – це катання
на велосипеді. Kayaking…
- Так…
- Так? На каяках. Hiking?
Це був той малюночок, коли
дітки йшли пішки у похід, так?
Swimming – плавання. Camping – це
коли ми з наметами йдемо у похід.
Fishing, again – риболовля.
Football – футбол.
Beach volleyball – пляжний волейбол.
І, мабуть, усі гри з м’ячем ми можемо
влітку практикувати і грати. Так? Добре.
Отже, що ми робимо зараз?
Нам треба буде знайти,
що у нас зайве. Так?
У нас буде 4 слова. Ось для вас приклад.
Наприклад, у нас є tent – це намет.
Sleeping bag – спальний мішок.
Ice skates – ковзани.
And compass – компас.
Отже, 3 слова, - вони до
якої діяльності належать?
- До літніх activities.
- До літніх activities, до camping, yeah?
If we want to go camping, we need a
tent, a sleeping bag and a compass –
коли ми йдемо із наметами
у похід, нам потрібен намет,
нам потрібен компас, щоб не заблукати
і нам потрібен спальний
мішок. Чи потрібні нам ковзани?
- Навряд.
- Навряд. Звичайно, можна їх
спакувати про всяк випадок, але ж…
У цьому ряду вони точно зайві.
Отже, тепер буде завдання для вас.
Ви повинні будете подумати,
що зайве буде у цих словах.
Отже, перше у нас – volleyball,
football, basketball and cycling.
- Cycling.
- Cycling. А чому?
- Тому що це все пов’язане
з м’ячем, а останнє слово…
- А на велосипеді можна
просто їхати і тримати м’яча.
Тоді його можна не викидати
з цього ряду, так? Добре.
Let’s try this one: camping,
kayaking, hiking, skiing.
- Якщо ми подумаємо про
це, що отут у нас є зайвим?
- Зайве - skiing.
- Skiing, а чому ж воно зайве?
- А тому, що не пов’язаний з
кемпінгом, каякінгом і хайкінгом
- Тому, що skiing ми не
можемо займатися влітку,
- ми не можемо кататися
на лижах, правильно?
А всі інші заняття ми можемо
робити влітку. Правильно? Okay.
And the last one: ice fishing,
skating, skiing and rock climbing.
Давайте тепер подумаємо. Ice
fishing – це у нас риболовля зимова.
Skating – катання на
ковзанах. Skiing – це у нас лижі.
І у нас є rock climbing.
- Цей, гірський туризм. Але
взимку теж можна займатись.
- Взимку можна, але, зазвичай,
ми цього не робимо, правда?
Все ж таки, ми більше
відносимо це до літніх занять.
Тому, що у нас зайве?
- Rock climbing.
- Rock climbing, чудово. Climbing –
ми літеру b не читаємо – “climing”.
І перевіряємо, чи так ми
все правильно зробили.
Так, у нас був зайвий cycling,
зайвий skiing і rock climbing.
Правильно? Чудово.
Так, що ми зробимо тепер?
Для того, щоб ми ще раз
повторили всі ці слова, які ми вже,
сподіваюся, вивчили, ми
повинні розділити наш зошиток -
ви також можете зробити разом зі
мною, якщо хочете – на дві частини.
Ми напишемо “In Summer”, “In Winter”.
І подумаємо, що ми можемо робити
влітку, і що ми можемо робити взимку.
І я це також буду робити разом із вами.
Отже, ми можемо поділити нашу
дошку або зошит на дві частини.
Тут ми пишемо In Summer -
що ми можемо робити влітку. І
що ми можемо робити взимку.
Так? А тепер я буду це робити на дошці,
ви можете переписувати собі в зошит.
І будете мені допомагати.
Отже, fishing, куди ми його відправимо?
- But… Fishing – in winter.
- Так, але у нас просто fishing.
Тому, якщо це просто fishing…
- In summer.
- Так, і там, і там. Але спочатку ми
його віднесемо більше в літо, добре?
Бо воно не ice fishing, а
просто fishing. Так? Добре.
Один є.
Rock climbing, без b, так? Rock “climing”.
- Літо.
- In summer.
- Так, чудово.
Далі: чи можемо ми прочитати це заняття?
- Skiing.
- Skiing, що таке skiing?
- Лижі.
- Лижі, чудово. Куди
ми відправляємо лижі?
- In winter.
- In winter. Чудово.
- У нас сьогодні прекрасні
учні. Так, what about this one?
- Making a snowman – in winter.
- In winter. Making a snowman –
сніговика ми можемо робити
або снігову бабу in winter.
Так?
Ось він. У нас вже один
fishing є влітку, а цей у нас…
- Зимовий.
- Ice fishing, зимовий. Отже, ми його
відправляємо дуже далеко у зиму.
Так.
- Cycling!
- Це cycling!
- Це чудова пісня про bicycle.
Yeah, cycling – in summer.
Так, що у нас ще є?
Давайте спробуємо це прочитати.
- Beach volleyball – in summer.
- Beach volleyball – in summer. Чудово.
Ще трошечки, ще
декілька у нас залишилось.
- Winter.
- Ви це точно знаєте, snowboarding.
- In winter.
- Winter, чудово.
- Snow… та що ж таке…
- Наступне у нас дуже гарний вид спорту.
- Ice skating – ковзани.
- Ice skating – ковзани?
- In winter.
Ice skating. І залишилось у
нас лише два. Ось це, легеньке.
- Hockey – in winter.
Так, і останнє…
- Camping.
- Camping - літо.
- In summer.
- Коли ми з наметами йдемо у похід.
Чудово, ви прекрасно
справилися з цим завдання.
Чудово! І мені здається, що ви
вже пам’ятаєте майже всі слова.
Добре, що у нас далі?
Grammar time! Куди ж без граматики?
Ї буде зовсім трішечки, але вона
має бути. Все дуже-дуже просто.
Ми повторюємо prepositions
of place – прийменники місця.
Дуже страшно звучить, але це малесенькі
слова, які нам допомагають говорити
про те, де ми або якісь
предмети, чи люди, чи будь-то,
будь-що, знаходиться в просторі. Так?
Отже, тут все дуже легко. Ви бачите
м’яч, ви бачите коробочку і є слова.
Давайте з найпростіших почнемо.
В – in. На – on. Під – under.
За – behind. Попереду
– in front of, чудово.
Над – above. Під – below.
Between – це я вже за вас
сказала – між. І поряд – next to.
Чудово. Так, я думаю, що ви їх знаєте.
Але ми зараз попрактикуємося
і ми ще раз їх повторимо.
А ось ті прийменники
– це прийменники часу.
Тобто вони дуже схожі на ті,
які у нас прийменники місця.
І треба розуміти, де які
треба використовувати
Отже, коли ми хочемо сказати,
що ми щось робимо вранці,
ми говоримо – in the morning.
Вдень – in the afternoon.
Ввечері – in the evening.
Якщо ми говоримо про місяць,
наприклад, February –
лютий – in February.
Коли ми говоримо про пори
року, наприклад, на весні – in spring.
In summer, in autumn, in winter.
Можемо говорити з артиклем, можемо
без. Тобто – in the summer або in summer.
Так? І коли ми говоримо про якийсь рік,
наприклад, 2020-ий – in 2020
(twenty-twenty). Так? Використовуємо in.
Коли ми говоримо про дати або
якісь визначні дати, наприклад,
день народження або
якесь свято, ми говоримо – on.
On my birthday I went camping
with my friends, наприклад.
Я пішов у похід із моїми
друзями на мій день народження.
On my birthday, дуже схоже на українську,
так? На мій день народження, так?
Або, наприклад, 5-го травня –
on the 5th of May. Також буде on.
Або в неділю – on Saturday.
Тут трошки відрізняється.
Українською ми говоримо в
неділю, а тут у нас виходить на.
Але треба запам’ятати. Коли ми
говоримо про час, використовуємо at.
Наприклад: о 10-ій - at 10 o'clock.
На вихідних – at the weekend.
І також є одне виключення.
Вночі буде – at night, а не in the night.
Ну чомусь in: in the morning – вранці,
in the afternoon – вдень
і ввечері – in the evening.
Але тільки вночі у нас буде
at night. Запам’ятовуємо.
Отже, для того щоб все
це нам краще запам’ятати
і попрактикувати ще більше,
у нас буде маленька гра.
Остання на сьогодні.
Дуже-дуже легка. Це – доміно
Ви всі знаєте, як грати в доміно.
От у нас будуть такі доміношки,
які ми повинні будемо разом скласти,
використовуючи прийменники часу й місця.
Добре? Отже, що ми робимо?
У нас з вами є такі окремі доміношки
із малюночками і із
прийменниками місця й часу.
Можливо, давайте краще я вам їх дам,
ви собі їх розкладете і будете обирати,
яким буде наступний малюночок
та підпис. Добре? Будь ласка.
- Дякую.
- Можете собі їх розкласти як вам зручно.
- А ви щось собі залишили?
- А це перше, бачите? Це старт, щоб
ви зрозуміли, звідки ми починаємо.
Я вже можу його прикріпити, щоб
ви знали, що вам далі треба шукати.
Давайте разом почитаємо.
On a nice summer day
– в чудовий літній день.
We went camping with my friends.
Так, отже, що нам треба знайти?
Нам треба знайти малюночок
чудового літнього дня.
- Це вечір, вогнище горить.
- Ну ось, напевне.
- Ще щось шукаємо, там має бути чудовий…
- А ось!
- Ні-ні, ще одне, ще одне.
- Ось, просто чудовий літній день. Так,
давайте мені сюди, я його прикріплю.
І будемо читати далі.
At 10 o'clock – at, так?
Коли ми говоримо про час, ми говоримо at.
At 10 o'clock all the tents were put
up. Ми вже поставили всі намети.
Так, put up a tent – це
поставити/розкласти намет.
-Tents, yes, all tents…
- All the tents were put up – всі намети
вже були розкладені/поставлені.
О 10-ій годині. Отже, що ми
повинні знайти? Годинничок, так?
Там де має бути 10-та година.
І намети, які вже всі стоять.
- We put up the tents – 3!
- Orange tent was mine.
It was between a red tent and brown one.
- Чудово, що таке between - головне слово?
- Між.
- Між, правильно. Значить, що у нас
є? У нас є 3 намети. Яких кольорів?
Orange – помаранчевий.
- Orange – помаранчевий.
- Orange. Yellow. Green?
- Red, вони всі разом
мають бути на малюночку.
- От вони, які там кольори?
- Red, orange and brown. Ось!
- Orange, red and brown. Так?
І помаранчевий має бути
між червоним і коричневим.
- Так.
-Чудово, давайте я прикріплю.
Отже, ви знайшли ось цю і вже
ту, яка слідує за нею.
Бачите? Ось у нас 10 годин.
Потім у нас, ми розклали
всі намети і мій намет
був помаранчевий, який був
між червоним, та коричневим.
Можемо так прикріпити, щоб було веселіше.
Так, поки що все йде
добре. Що у нас далі?
My lazy friend was sleeping
in his tent. In – це у нас де?
- В. Спав всередині намету.
- Так, my lazy friend – мій
лінивий друг спав в наметі,
поки всі збирали дрова і
щось робили, готували їжу.
- Запалювали… багаття…
- Вогнище розводили,
так? А він спав у наметі.
Давайте знайдемо цього лінивого друга.
- Ось я знайшов! In front
of the tent we've made a fire.
- Так, отже він спав,
лінивий, у своєму наметі. Так?
І що нам тепер треба шукати?
In front of – це що означає?
Попереду, так. Перед
наметом ми розвели вогонь.
- Вогнище, вогнище… От,
перед наметом вогнище.
- Чудово, дякую.
- Якщо б не я то… Ти знав?
- Так, що тут у нас далі?
Under – це у нас де? Під.
Under the “camping” sign
there was a pair of boots.
Це важкеньке. Under
the “camping” sign. Sign…
- Навіщо перевертаєте?
- Під…
- Під кемпінгом…
- Під “camping” sign, що таке
sign? Це – такий знак. Так?
Має бути десь знак, на
якому написано “camping”.
- Ось, і на ньому висять чоботи.
- А під ним, так – a pair of boots.
- Над знаком висять…
- Гріються.
- Під – under. Під знаком висять
чоботи. Так? Є така картиночка?
- Є, але ми б сказали на знаку
висять. Ні? Під знаком, під табличкою?
- Вони ж під табличкою, якраз,
знаходяться. Добре, що у нас далі?
Давайте читати. High up in
the sky – в небі – above our heads.
Above – це де? Над нашими головами
the sun was shining nicely.
- Світить сонце чарівно.
- Чарівно світить сонце. Де це сонечко?
- Ось, над. A thick forest
was behind our camp…
- Чудово. Ось воно, сонечко, яке above
our heads – над нашими головами в небі.
A thick forest was
behind. Behind – це де?
- Ліс був позаду.
- Ховається. Позаду був дуже густий ліс.
Ну, він там такий, не дуже густий,
але де у нас картиночка, де є ліс?
- Ось. Давай-давай, ти.
- Та он ліс.
- Ні, там ще люди є, а тут тільки ліс.
- Так, чудово. Ось у нас ліс який є
behind the tent. І що у нас тут написано?
- It was a very nice day – це був
чарівний день. It was a fantastic…
Це був фантастичний день.
Out with my friends – який я провів…
- На вулиці, на свіжому
повітрі із моїми друзями.
Так приліпимо.
І остання, якраз, картиночка.
- Фініш.
- Так і ми прийшли разом
до фінішу. Молодці, чудово!
Ми все склали, цілі, неушкоджені.
Чудовий день описали,
історію склали. Прекрасно!
На цьому сьогодні все, дуже вам дякую.
- Дуже вам дякую.
- І вам дякую.
- Ви чудові учні. На сьогодні все.
Прекрасний дуже проект, тому що
ми маємо допомагати один одному і,
головне, коли ти навчаєшся – ти
згадуєш, як це було, коли навчалася
ти і думаєш: «Ай, треба було
слухати вчительку, маму, тата».
Дуже приємно, бо я ж навчався
за тих часів, коли контакт
«вчитель-учень» був трошки інший.
Зараз ти відчуваєш, що ви на рівних,
що немає такого переляку
від авторитету вчителя.
Все зрозуміло, все
наглядно, якісь вправи.
Мені взагалі здається, що це –
такий солідний і дуже
потребуючий уваги проект.
Тому що вже давно кажуть,
що маємо колись перейти
на дистанційне вивчення
будь-якого предмету.
І це надає якусь рівну можливість дітям.
Не всі можуть навчатися
в Києві, це зрозуміло.
І мати на вибір ту
вчительку, яку вони хочуть.
Знаєте, цеглинка за цеглинкою може
збудуємо якесь інше відношення до освіти,
до взаємовідносин в
своїй країні один до одного.